vuelven las restricciones en américa
latina ante el repunte de los contagios
de kobe 19 colombia está sumida en una
tercera ola de la pandemia actividad
hospitalaria ya colapsado en ciudades
como medellín donde decenas de pacientes
esperan una cama en las unidades de
cuidados intensivos otros están siendo
trasladados en dosis aéreas a otras
localidades ante este rebrote el
gobierno ha impuesto un confinamiento
estricto en cuatro ciudades a partir de
la noche del jueves y esas son medidas
de carácter preventivo para evitar un
movimiento grande de contagios seguir
teniendo capacidad de respuesta en el
sistema hospitalario circunstancias
similares también serán aplicadas en
otras ciudades capitales si bien las
autoridades tienen que darse en casa es
una realidad lejana para aquellos que
viven del diario una región donde el
trabajo informal prevalece y la crisis
económica se ha agudizado con la
academia lo que pasa es que te enfermo
de la función te va abriendo los
servicios de comer yo sé que esta
persona que no tengo que irme de datos
dice el gobierno no te ayuda a mí nunca
miente alguna ayuda de edad en argentina
el gobierno de alberto fernández
endureció el miércoles del toque de
queda en el área
metropolitana de la capital buenos
aires- a partir del lunes y hasta el 30
de abril los estudiantes también vuelven
a la modalidad virtual desde las 20
horas hasta las 6 de la mañana no se
puede circular por las calles
he dispuesto que quedan suspendidas
todas las actividades recreativas
sociales culturales deportivas y
religiosas que se hagan en lugares
cerrados que estas medidas incluyen
también la suspensión de clases mientras
que en perú la capital y otras 42
provincias están en riesgo extremo por
la tercera ola de contagios y vuelven
las restricciones a partir del 19 de
abril por tres semanas otras naciones
latinoamericanas como ecuador están
barajando bloqueos un año después del
inicio de la pandemia